Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Im Rahmen des Mercedes-Benz Junior Cups in Sindelfingen hatte ich die Möglichkeit mit einigen Trainern über Jugendfußball zu sprechen. Das hört ihr jetzt in dieser etwas besonderen Folge des Kurzpasses. Hallo und herzlich willkommen liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht noch, im letzten Jahr schon habe ich eine Episode, einen Kurzpass beim Junior Cup in Sindelfingen produziert. Und damals auch schon den Hinweis vorausgeschickt, den ich jetzt auch nochmal platzieren möchte, ich war da nicht primär für den Rasenfunk, sondern beruflich. Das heißt, ich habe da noch einen kleinen Job, einen sehr schönen Job, einer der letzten meiner Tätigkeiten aus meiner alten Selbstständigkeit, der ich nachgehe. Und dementsprechend sei an der Stelle eben der Hinweis gemacht, wenn euch das stört, dass ich da quasi beruflich war und das primär mit dem Rasenfunk erst mal nichts zu tun hatte, der ja auch werbe- und sponsorenfrei ist, dann hört diese Folge nicht. Ich empfehle euch, hört sie. Und ihr könnt ja besonders genau hinhören, ob ich vielleicht diesem Turnier besonders positiv gegenüberstehe, weil ich eben da auch mit vielen netten Menschen tatsächlich zusammenarbeite und eben auch einen kleinen Teil meines Geldes darüber verdiene. Also dieser Hinweis sei vorausgeschickt und noch einiges anderes sollte ich zu dieser Folge erklären. Es ist ein bisschen eine besondere Folge, denn sie setzt sich zusammen aus mehreren Einzelgesprächen, die ich führen konnte. Es gab eine Art Mixed Zone, in der man die Möglichkeit hatte, mit den Trainern der beteiligten Teams zu sprechen. Es waren vor Ort zum Beispiel der FC Liverpool, der FC Bayern, Hertha BSC, VfB Stuttgart, Atlanta United, die Glasgow Rangers und Rapid Wien gewonnen hat das Turnier Liverpool. Dazu gibt es dann auch noch mal eine extra Folge, wobei wir das damals noch nicht wussten. Erklär ich euch am Ende dieses Kurzpasses. Der Rahmen war dann ebenso, wie er in einer Mixed Zone auch ist. Das heißt, die Trainer haben sich platziert in einem kleinen Raum und dann hatte jeder Journalist, jeder Journalistin, jeder Blogger, jeder Influencer, wer auch immer da alles vor Ort war, die Möglichkeit, mit den Trainern ein Gespräch zu führen. Ich habe mir dann diejenigen geschnappt, die gerade Zeit hatten, weil ich versuchen wollte, auch in diesem Rahmen ein bisschen die Rasenfunkatmosphäre zumindest teilweise herzustellen. Das heißt, zu versuchen, ein etwas tiefer gehendes Gespräch zu führen. Ich dachte, es wäre dafür ganz gut, wenn ich mir quasi nicht die Gesprächspartner mit Journalisten und Kollegen teilen muss, weil sie sich dann eben ganz auf meine Fragen konzentrieren können. Dementsprechend ist es auch eine interessante Auswahl geworden. Ihr werdet jetzt drei Gespräche hören, ich werde sie jeweils kurz ankündigen und dann einfügen. Zuerst mit Tony Annan, dem Leiter der Nachwuchsakademie von Atlanta United. Mit ihm habe ich über einige interessante Dinge gesprochen. Das ist auch das längste Gespräch geworden. Dann hörte noch Michael Hartmann, Trainer der U19 von Hertha BSC und am Ende Nico Willig, Trainer der U19 des VfB Stuttgart. Und eine Anmerkung dazu noch, weil das im Rahmen einer Mixed-Song passiert ist, ist die Tonqualität logischerweise auch anders, als ihr es im Rasenfunk gewohnt seid. Das heißt, im Hintergrund gibt es immer wieder Geräusche. Ich hoffe, sie stören nicht zu sehr. Ich habe so viel rausgefiltert, wie noch zu machen war. Ich hoffe, es ist für euch dennoch interessant. Beim Abhören hat die Qualität bei mir ausgereicht, dass ich es in allen Situationen hören konnte. Ich hoffe, euch geht es ähnlich. Jetzt würde ich aber sagen, legen wir los. Als erstes folgt das längste von allen drei Gesprächen. Das ist auch die Reihenfolge, in der ich sie gehalten habe, an diesem Abend. Vielleicht erkennt ihr auch ein Muster in der Moderation. Ich musste mich auch selbst erstmal ein bisschen anpassen an diese Situation. Jetzt hören wir Tony Annan von Atlanta United. Ich habe ihn ein bisschen über das Turnier ausgefragt, aber es ging mir dann viel eher um die Jugendarbeit bei Atlanta United und in den USA generell. Ich habe da auch an viele Dinge angeknüpft, die euer Feedback waren zu unserer Folge mit Jürgen Kalver zur MLS und dem Sieg von Atlanta United im Meisterschaftsfinale. Ich habe versucht, da ein bisschen anzuknüpfen, ein paar Fragen zu stellen, auch ein paar Anmerkungen zu machen, die ihr noch hattet. Und ich fand, dass wirklich ein sehr interessantes Gespräch draus geworden ist. Man konnte Tony Annan wirklich jede Frage hinwerfen. Er hat auf jede sehr, sehr sportlich und sehr interessant reagiert. Und ich fand, er hat auch an gewissen Punkten kein Blatt vor den Mund genommen. Das empfand ich als sehr angenehm. Aber jetzt wird einfach selber rein. Es geht los mit Tony Annan von Atlanta United.
Und was probieren Sie da aus?
Ich habe zum Beispiel in der Saison zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben auf Dreierkette umgestellt. Ich hatte einfach das Gefühl, es sitzt Zeit dazu, es passt total gut zu den Spielern. Und dann habe ich gesagt, jetzt musst du dich als Trainer flexibel umstellen, nicht in deinem Lieblingssystem festhalten, sondern jetzt stellen wir das um. Und innerhalb kurzer Zeit es ihnen zu vermitteln, das war dann die Kunst und die Überzeugung zu schaffen. Und wenn man jetzt die Tabelle anguckt und die Spiele und die Art und Weise, wie wir spielen, dann hat das glaube ich ganz gut funktioniert. Und auf einmal haben wir etwas Neues entwickelt. Ich kann aber jetzt nicht mit Sicherheit sagen, dass wir das bis zum Saisonende machen, wenn ich im März das Gefühl habe, da könnte mal wieder was anderes stattfinden, dann müssen wir vielleicht wieder was anderes stattfinden. Das gehört auch dazu.
Was war denn das Lieblingssystem?
Wir haben vor eineinhalb Jahren 4-2-2-2 gespielt.
Oh, in der Hoffenheimer-Variante mit Flach, Flach, Flach?
Ja, in der Hoffenheimer-Variante, aber auch in der Leipziger-Variante.
Entschuldigung, ich meinte Leipzig.
Also Leipziger-Variante. Wir haben uns da auch ein bisschen was abgeschaut, sicherlich. Wir haben uns dann aber auch jetzt ein bisschen umumstellen müssen, weil es einfach besser zu den Spielern gepasst hat. Und das gehört auch dazu.
Jetzt beruht ja so ein System, gerade bei Leipzig beruht ja darauf, den Gegner so sehr unter Druck zu setzen in bestimmten Zonen des Feldes, dass der Ballverlust sehr wahrscheinlich ist und der Weg zum Tor dann auch relativ kurz. Ist es denn einfacher, einen Ballverlust zu provozieren im Nachwuchsfußball?
Bei uns war es so, dass wir beim VfB schon den Ball sehr stark im Mittelpunkt haben und den eigenen Ball besitzen konnten. Das ist das Paradoxe, die Leipziger Grundordnung, aber die hat bei uns bewirkt, dass wir dadurch vier zentrale Mittelfeldspieler hatten. Damit konnten wir einfach noch eine höhere Zentrumsdominanz im eigenen Ballbesitz entwickeln. Das hat sich dadurch total positiv entwickelt.
Standen die dann im Korridor oder standen die diagonal für die Passwinkel?
Zwei, zwei, zwei, die standen da und dann mit den Spitzen. Damit konnten sie richtig schön... Klar, da hast du dann noch die zwei Spitzen, die tief, und dann hast du Dreieckbildungen dadurch, die, wenn du es dann leicht verschiebst, aber nicht grundsätzlich die Raute. Und so konnten wir dann relativ viele Situationen außen-innen schaffen mit Positionswechseln. Wir haben dann auch Gegenfuß gespielt, also zum Beispiel der rechte Zehner war einfach ein Linksfuß, der sich etwas breiter freimacht, dann innen reinzieht und so. Das sind so Dinge, die wir dann geschaffen haben und es war schwierig für den Gegner Zuordnungen zu finden. Er hatte ja auch nie vier zentrale Mittelfeldspieler. Jetzt weiß ich aber den Ausgangspunkt der Frage nicht mehr.
Ich habe gefragt, ob es schwieriger ist, genau. Oder ist es schwieriger, das Pressing einzuüben? Ich habe beides noch nicht gemacht, ich bin leider kein professioneller Fußballspieler.
Nein, aber Balleroberung, Ballgewinn gehört dazu. Und ob das jetzt mannschaftstaktisch ist, das muss nicht immer mannschaftstaktisch sein, weil im Endeffekt geht es um die Qualität eines Spielers, um eine Spelle zu erobern und Momente zu erkennen, wann er losgehen kann, um Pässe abzufangen, wann er losgehen kann, in einen Zweikampf zu kommen. Und das muss man, glaube ich, bei Ihnen schulen. Und das gehört genauso dazu unten wie oben.
Aber Sie würden jetzt nicht sagen, bei Jugendfußballern, also beim Gegner dann, die ja mit diesem Stress auch umgehen müssen, ist es wahrscheinlicher, dass das zum Ball Verlust führt, weil sie so eine Situation ja auch noch gar nicht so häufig erlebt haben, jetzt gerade gegen so ein wildes 4-2-2-2.
Ja, wenn es der Gegner nicht gewöhnt ist, dann tut er sich sicherlich dann schwer. Dann ist es schon ein Vorteil. Andererseits, wie jedes System auch da, seine Schwächen, wenn er nicht analysiert hat, dann kann er auch wieder Mittel dagegen finden. Von dem her, das war phasenweise leichter, das war aber auch manchmal schwerer. Das ist schon ein schwieriges Ball zu betreiben.
Okay, ich habe hier schon eine 5-Minuten-Warnung gekommen, deswegen habe ich jetzt eine letzte Frage. Welche Spieler in Ihrer Mannschaft soll ich im Auge behalten? Sie dürfen nicht sagen, alle. Das lasse ich nicht durchgehen.
Im Auge behalten? Ja, ich glaube, dass es schon Spieler bei uns gibt, wir haben Nationalspieler, die sind schon in dem Auge, würde ich jetzt einmal sagen. Ich glaube, es gibt schon Spieler wie Nick Betzner oder Kevin Grimm, Alexander Kopf, die momentan nicht ganz als Top-Spieler in ihrem Jahrgang behandelt werden und die trotzdem aufgrund ihrer Körperlichkeit noch nicht so endgültig entwickelt sind und die da noch Schritte machen werden, weil sie einfach fleißige, kluge und technisch sehr gute Spieler sind. Ich glaube, dass wir die nächsten Jahre schon noch ein paar Schritte gehen können und vielleicht noch ein oder zwei noch mehr in die Öffentlichkeit.
Genau die werde ich jetzt im Auge überhalten. Soweit Nico Willig, Trainer der U19 des VfB Stuttgart. Das waren die drei Gespräche, die ich führen konnte im Rahmen dieser Mixed Zone. Ich hoffe, es hat euch gefallen. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen eine andere Folge als sonst. Ich habe versucht, ins Detail reinzugehen, aber logischerweise kann man dennoch nur an der Oberfläche kratzen. Ich fand dennoch alle drei Gespräche für sich genommen hatten interessante Aspekte, auch unterschiedliche Aspekte. Mir hat das besonders gut gefallen. Ich hoffe, bei euch kommt es ebenso auf Anklang. Gebt gerne Feedback unter mitmachen.rasen.de. Das ist auch nicht die einzige Kurzpass-Folge, die ich vor Ort in Sindelfingen aufgezeichnet habe. Was ebenfalls erscheinen wird noch im Laufe dieser Woche, ist ein Interview mit zwei Liverpooler Podcastern, Bloggern, YouTubern, die Anfitrap waren zu Gast in Sindelfingen. Ich habe mit ihnen gesprochen über Jürgen Klopp, was sich beim Liverpool FC so getan hat, wie sie auf das Champions-League-Achtelfinale gegen den FC Bayern vorausblicken. Das alles erscheint in Kürze auf rasen.de. Ich danke euch für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Ich bin gespannt auf eure Rückmeldungen.